to balance out the team's a little bit
I'm gonna go with Gallagher guy Galaga
guy now they're finally getting a little
fun over there okay that's good
that man is playing Galaga the screen
junkies show brought to you by
Squarespace build your own website
regardless of skill level with
Squarespace what's going on guys
something pretty cool in studio here
today we're lucky to have the directors
of Captain America Civil War and Captain
America Winter Soldier Joe Russo and
Anthony Russo gentlemen first let me
thank you for delivering the goods with
Captain America Civil War some of the
best action one of the best superhero
films I've ever seen well that's awesome
very much thank that so without giving
too much away the airport scene might be
the best action scene in the history of
comic book movies how much pressure did
you feel to get that scene just right
and did you use toys to practice oh my
god great great questions like look
right from the moment that we decided to
go down the road of Civil War for Cap's
third movie yeah we knew that that scene
was going to be the centerpiece of the
movie I mean it had the most pressure on
it you can imagine we spent months and
months prepping it and yeah there were
figures involved because it's hard that
fight is so big it was very difficult
for us to always track where everybody
was at any given moment in that fight
okay again without giving too much away
or all everybody knows our fans know
that Spidey is in the movie how
important was Spidey to the story was
there a with Spidey and without Spidey
version there never was I mean I think
at one point there was a conversation
where Marcus McFeely were asked to
remove Spidey if the deal didn't work
out it was not an issue that we it was
not a moment that we paid a lot of
attention to because we as directors
knew that the deal was so complicated to
get done if you give anybody the the
inclination that the movie can be
accomplished without that character in
it they may want to back away to be a
real AI Felix yeah oh yeah so we just
kept saying that the movie is not
accomplished without this character in
it approve goddamn on Facebook asks how
do you balance and give attention to
each of the superheroes in Civil War
from the beginning of our journey
filmmakers Joe and I have always loved
in Sambas yeah you like our first movie
welcome to Collinwood was an ensemble a
lot of our TV work arrested community
happy endings all in samba 'ls we take
passes where we think about the story
from beginning to end even though it's
Captain America's movie you know we will
step through the story from every other
characters point of view literally so
that you can file the character from the
moment they enter the story to the
moment they exit the story and we just
think about them the whole movie as
there is for a moment there's going to
be somebody in the movie theater that
came to the movie just for that one
character no matter how much screen time
they have so you want to make sure that
fan gets the best experience they could
possibly have see the character do some
really cool things do some surprising
things have an emotional arc that's very
engaging and relatable so the whole the
whole package so we try to build even if
even for very small amounts of screen
time we try to build something
satisfying and fun and figure out the
coolest thing we can do with that
character and how they can intersect
with the bigger story you have former
friends Iron Man and Captain America
clashing another big superhero battle
just happened Batman V Superman did you
have any thoughts on that film and that
clash we haven't seen it yet I be honest
because we literally just delivered the
movie about four days ago and then
rolled right into press for this film I
think we had about 12 hours off have you
seen Deadpool yet he has seen deadpool
tim miller is a very good friend of ours
could you ever see deadpool jumping into
the MCU you'd love to see Deadpool yeah
up into the air how great would that be
a great thing about Marvel is like not
you know you yeah there is an attitude
of nothing's impossible but that doesn't
mean everything is possible you just
have to chase it guys thank you for
taking time to answer those questions
now I'd like to shift gears we are going
to have the ultimate MCU fantasy draft
Anthony Russo and Joe Russo brother
verse brother are going to pick their
teams of superheroes and participants in
the Marvel Universe and we will decide
who has the ultimate team of Marvel
heroes let's do this fellas to decide
who picks first classic
rock-paper-scissors rock-paper-scissors
one two three I thought if Anthony come
out yep you have the number one choice
Anthony okay look I know what Joe is
worried about it
actually what he's worried about someone
to keep keep the game interesting and
since this is a Captain America movie
I'm gonna go with cap Avengers here's
the great thing about cap if he doesn't
lead you to victory he will at least
guarantee that you lose gracefully he
made a very popular choice okay
strategically though critique Lee I am
going to go with Scarlet Witch it is the
most powerful character so making a
power play right out of the gate Anthony
what are you guys I will go with vision
X boom thank you this Joe's going for
the Power Move I've got him alright a
Power Move okay I'm gonna go with or
anyone else is Odin up there because I
think Odin would whip some Thor ass
let's call that check we've been a fight
alright if we're gonna go with the
Asgardians I think a team-up of four and
Heimdall as Guardians flying off the
board how could they not Yeah right I
wish to know how that happened I will go
with Hulk yeah you know he's still
sitting up there all alone joonie job it
was smart to have a run on as Guardians
mm-hm and I'm gonna continue that run
and I'm gonna take Lady SIF there you go
I've got this completely under control
this is exactly what the writing room
looks like okay sit down with Markus
McFeely we actually have a board like
this with the characters on it if you
believe it and we do move around this
we're trying to figure out storytelling
that's awesome it's really true yeah
okay I got to go with Iron Man gotta go
Iron Man I am Iron Man they may be at
odds in Civil War but right here
Captain America and Iron Man fighting
look at that you know I have to go with
a deceptively powerful character who in
the books is almost as strong as the
Hulk spider-man Spidey is nice
hey everyone Joe's favorite character
growing up so it's fitting I'm going to
go with Stanley next because he clearly
can't die yes
no that's a very good power I hope you
didn't just curse him okay
eggshell shield that just allowed let's
just open a door for me to make a run on
some more props there I'm gonna go with
Groot I am Groot every time you take the
foot off the gas he seizes the
opportunity Anthony he's very serious on
that level one of the considerations
here which team would be more fun to
hang out with who'd be better in the
locker room you've cleared it up Howard
the Duck Howard hit duck thank you thank
you for that roast to balance out the
team's a little bit I'm gonna go with
Gallagher guy Galaga guy yep now they're
finally getting a little fun over there
okay that's good that man is playing
Galaga I have it on good authority that
Scarlett Johansson will be very upset if
she's being a key player in your films
but not on anyone's team is definitely
consideration but I also can't keep cap
and Bucky apart so the Winter Soldier in
the homeless book alright to counteract
that I'm gonna take Panther a
devastating strong new character
I'm hearing my daughter's voice in my
head which recently said to me yeah you
know a lot of people think Hawkeye is
old-fashioned but I just love him he's
so amazing with the arrows that says
Hawkeye move out of motion none of this
makes sense I'm gonna burst the TV
buh-bye my trap Jessica Jones I'm just
trying to make a living you know blues
costs money are we ever gonna see any
crossover between the MCU in the TV well
oh he just did okay there you go ha ha
weighted weight as a size 7 that
question now I will go for Black Widow
okay there we go
Andrew secure I'm gonna go with ant-man
ant-man I wanted him well you haven't
heard of me
now you wouldn't have heard of me to
make the leader of my team happy I'm
gonna bring his his other besties Falcon
over get myself Alcon it's really
important to me that cap never finds out
about this uh war machine boom boom
star-lord star-lord
whoo star-lord man I'm gonna go with
another of my favorite characters
growing up the Punisher oh yeah
badass okay fine we're down to the final
four picks dynamics between my team
players I feel like that's a big part of
the equation
history so you know I'm gonna get Nick
Fury over there to really like make
everything work properly we need the
coach if you want to stay hit me you
need to keep both
let me see here I do I need a leader
well take Howard Stark not only brother
versus brother anymore yup other versus
son Wow
we are ready a lot of daddy issues you
have Odin over here versus over there
did that I am going to go with happy
Hogan because I am so grateful to Jon
Favreau
for kicking off the entire MCU with the
amazing iron yes badge guys put a medal
in the toilet come on that's a very
emotional pick it's hard for me to Trump
that and as I'm gonna have to do I
cannot leave this character on the board
lest I incur the wrath of all of the
Marvel TV verse fans I'm gonna take
daredevil daredevil take your shot
there you go now for Quicksilver sitting
up there he's dead it's true it's not
real it's kind of a lame duck pic but
yeah all of this is pretend that's right
well there you have it guys team Joe
Russo team Anthony Russo who do you
think will dominate this epic Marvel
smackdown let us know in the comments
section below tell us who would win and
why we want to know I want to thank the
Russo brothers for taking the time to
make our dreams come true I don't want
to thank you for watching I'm Hal Rogers
can't me up on Twitter bye bye hey
screen junkies want to see the Russo
brothers give their epic commentary to
our honest trailer for the Winter
Soldier then click the box or the
description below to see them take our
trailer team to task and give
behind-the-scenes insights on the making
of the film check it out thanks to
Squarespace we're sponsoring this
episode
build professional looking websites
regardless of your skill level with
Squarespace for more information click
the link in the description below